I've been working on the US history
content here for more than two years now
and we have a team of experts who've
been in the classroom for many years who
have advanced degrees in US history who
really rigorously write tape and edit
each other's work I think it would be
kind of like a day's work class
everything that we've done on the Khan
Academy website meets the AP
requirements so teachers can feel
confident that when they send their
students to watch a video or read an
article or practice with an exercise on
Khan Academy but students are taking
away the key learning objectives that
they should get for the AP exam it's a
frequent misconception that people in
this time period thought that the world
was flat we really wanted to make this
material approachable and fun and so
throughout I think students will see a
real enthusiasm for the material and a
sense of humor so that it's not just
reading a history textbook so I've
brought you here to talk about the
Gilded Age which is one of my favorite
eras of American history because
everything was great and covered in gold
it's really interacting with some of the
big questions of history and having an
opportunity to explore those with
enthusiasm no because it is the only era
of American history I can think of that
has a sarcastic name because it is fun
we hope to give students that sense that
history is not a boring subject it's
really fun